Would you consider Corser of Cruix a
draw spell? Actually, this one's an
unambiguous yes from me. It digs deeper
into your library by getting lands out
of the way, and it creates card
advantage by letting you play lands from
library instead of from your hand.
That's a draw engine. Now, you might
think, is it really card advantage to
play lands off the top and then let
lands pile up in your hand instead? And
yes, yes, it is. Anytime you play a land
off the top, imagine instead that it
went to your hand and you played a land
from your hand instead. Those lands
piling up in hand would be there if you
drew the cards instead. They just might
not be the exact same lands. If your
deck strongly cares about what exact
lands get played for land drops four,
five, six, and seven, maybe there's a
downside here. But for the other 95% of
decks, this card is just plain